what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
okay so picking up with EXO Manowar ah
this is actually really really cool the
way that Robert Van diddy does this
because this is like the pre luda planet
death right I mean find em I guess is
officially vol 3 this is kind of like
volume 2.5 if we had to give a numerical
designation but the way that vide does
is really really cool so keep in mind
with regards to that in comics their
whole making is their comics have to be
easily accessible it's like one of their
major tenets one of their major rules
that with Marvel it can be kind of
difficult to access their comics you
know for example in the next few weeks
or so probably halfway through March we
are going to put the brakes on Amazing
Spiderman we're going to cover map
fractions in what align and fist and
then we're going to come back to Amazing
Spiderman but you can't just like pick
up map fractions immortal iron fist
halfway through right like you really
can't do that because then you would be
totally confused you'd be like what in
the heck are the seven seven week cities
like one of the world's going on with
all that that's kind of the cool thing
the valiant has over Marvel and DC is
that they're really easy to just kind of
jump into and that's the whole point
with bending right I mean when you start
going through this whole EXO Manowar you
have Volume one that introduces you to
EXO to eric of day CF vol 2 which is the
introduction of men jack in the EXO
Manowar mythos and then you have volume
3 which is him taking back off to planet
death so in volume 2 we had talked about
how the exo-armor basically was kind of
considered to be something divine in the
sense of divine alien race look at the
armor of Shawn O'Hara as a divine piece
of armor something that was really
designed explicitly for them only they
should be able to wield it but when they
had gone around the universe when they
finally arrived on earth they had
grabbed a handful of human and they were
using them as a work force when Eric had
basically escaped when he had taken off
and he had bonded with the armor the
vine looked at this as though it was
basically blasphemy but that's not
something that should be allowed to
happen in addition to this when he had
taken off back home to earth the whole
idea and really what what Venditti is
building up to is kind of like this new
version of our Marines from you know
those guys remember remember valiant
back in the 1990's it's got like a
reimagining of our Marines and the sense
of the vine were terrified of the idea
that humanity would be able to
reverse-engineer this wildly powerful
armor and the result was that humanity
would effectively be able to take out
the entirety of the vine race once they
begin to mean with the armor and they
learn what the armor is about and they
learn the intentions of the vine and so
what we do is you basically take up with
this invasion fleet that's being sent to
earth for the purpose of wiping out all
of humanity and taking the armor back
now the other half of this is we pick a
with regards to the character of Ghazni
this is a crazy thing because remember
Goffe was believed to have been dead
when when eric had escaped of divine
mothership it was believed that Goffe
had been killed in the conflict what we
find out is that he's not instead he's
being used as an experiment of sorts
he's being used really as a method of
torture in order to find out more about
Eric remember the vine don't really know
anything about him all they know is that
it was a guy who just donned the armor
took off back to earth was able to evade
their their efforts to capture him and
this is basically led to this invasion
fleet what we also learn here is that
where we would look at the vine race and
say okay
they're basically a spacefaring cohesive
you know Society that it's not that case
there's trouble in paradise and the
reason why is because from a military
standpoint really from a governing
standpoint the armor if it can't be
retrieved needs to be destroyed but the
armor is considered to be divined by the
priests of the vine and so because of
this it would be it'd be tantamount to
destroying a religious relic it'd be
tantamount to destroying everything that
the entirety of the religion revolves
around and so for the priests of the
vine race it's just kind of like this
cannot be allowed to happen because if
it does it's tantamount to destroying
everything that our race believes in
everything our race follows but what we
find out here is that there's a really
tenuous situation between the military
and the priests themselves the military
doesn't really care anything about the
relics the religion you know they kind
of gets is about to be an archaic form
of thought the military really focuses
on what's happening right now now the
cool thing about this is that this is
like robber Venditti talking about the
modern day right I mean he's really kind
of drawing these metaphors for the
modern day and since there are a lot of
people that you know really of the
younger generation they kind of look
around and say okay religion is like an
archaic concept is the representation of
days gone by it's time to move past the
belief of deities and start focusing on
science but we can see where we can
focus on different things like that and
it creates this really strong dichotomy
I guess between those individuals that
have faith versus those that rely on
science it's one of those eternal
battles that will go on forever and ever
but at this point we transition over to
Alexander remember Alexander is a guy
who is basically working alongside XO
for the purpose of helping to try to
stave off this invasion the kicker to
this is that when when the whole team up
happened between Alexander and the team
up happened with ninja and with EXO
Alexander was basically banished he was
he was kicked out of the of the vine
race now this is everything I kind of
want to rehash for those individuals who
had a few questions what the vine were
doing earlier when they had first shown
up on earth is that they were basically
replaced
humans with vine replicant so that these
vine could basically have the remnants
left behind now under normal
circumstances the vine would just you
know leave these plantings behind they
would just kind of disappear and that
would be it you know they would never
really have a reason to come back yet so
Alexander told us but because of the
fact that Eric is here with the
exo-armor
they are coming back to earth but the
overall goal is for the plantings just
going to be mingled into normal society
so nobody would really know that they
were there and that was the role of
Alexander plate the other half of this
is that within the vine race you have
what are called gatherings and
gatherings are really just like these
telepathic gatherings of the vine from
across the universe so that you know be
somebody on earth could meet with you
know the head of the vine race or at
least one of the vine priests or
something like that on the other side of
the universe is the way to basically
communicate without having to travel
from one place to the next but the idea
here is that because Alexander has
basically been ousted from the vine race
he doesn't have any allies here all the
other plantings that were on his side
you know when he said hey look I need
your help they said nope you've been
ousted we don't want to have anything to
do with you and it creates a wildly
difficult situation because now he's on
his own it's just him and EXO he has no
information coming from anybody but the
cool thing about this is that this is
when robert van Diddy begins to dig a
little deeper and give us a little bit
more in terms of what this what does
this exo-armor is capable of in the
sense that we're eric is basically
wielding it and he's learning about it
as we're learning about it what we find
out is that this armor is capable of
tapping into these telepathic gatherings
now keep in mind Eric isn't actually
going anywhere like physically he's not
leaving anywhere instead what the armor
does is it just teleports his mind it
allows them to tap into this Kalla
Pathak a meeting between these various
members of the vine ways and the
plantings they have on earth now of
course this is also kind of funny too
and the reason why I say that is you
guys keep in mind Erica's not the
smartest tool in shed he comes from a
much older age of society and so with
him what we would consider to be like a
knife or a sword he finds something to
be recognizable for something like
meeting in this telepathic place he
doesn't recognize her he doesn't realize
it he's not in a physical location and
so he immediately starts attacking these
guys and of course they begin to kind of
make fun of him poke at him a bit say
hey look no there's no use for weapons
here but what this does is it actually
moves things toward the side of EXO
men-of-war and reason why I say that is
because now with the exo-armor able to
tap into these gatherings there's no
safe place for the vine to go there's no
safe refuge put in to meet discuss
battle tactics so on and so forth
without anybody knowing what's going on
instead if they can access it the
exo-armor can access it and so the
result is that they're basically kind of
forced to go back to the drawing boards
they basically kind of forced a panic
and so in this last little tidbit here
you notice this first part we of course
have commander trill now keep in mind
commander trill was really the one that
captured air when he first arrived on
earth commander Charles kind of like the
field commander I guess of the military
but he's also really depicted by Robert
Venditti to be very proud to be very
arrogant but to also be very very
skilled and this is really just kind of
this this major battle in a sense of the
two of these guys going against each
other it was the most logical outcome
and the reason why I say that is because
again you know something that I hope you
guys will notice is that XO Manowar kind
of goes in phases it's really an
organized in a structured way to read a
story which is one of the reasons why
it's so easily accessible you're
introduced to the character the
character is given a given a piece of
armor a piece of equipment that will
help them they character runs into
somebody who's basically a guide kind of
a mentor of sorts and then the character
goes on to fight their arch-nemesis it's
the classic hero's journey is basically
what it says and keeping it structured
keeping it you know organized keeping it
very easily accessible is what's helped
to make it so popular make it so so
successful but the idea is a commander
tril shows up about something that I
hope you guys notice is he shows up with
a small contingent it's him and two
other guys and this was just really the
arrogance of commander trail coming into
play in the sense that he believes
themselves to be just as capable as this
XO arm of the problem is that even with
Erik being very primitive in terms of
how he wields it the fact that he
doesn't reel it to its full potential
still shows he's wildly powerful in
terms of his abilities because he
overcomes both of these guys and then
starts taking the fight to commander
tril now here's what the whole situation
comes into play because commander tril
depicted himself with hey I'm a man of
honor I'm a man of combat I do what it
takes I will I'll fight you to the death
but then we basically find out that he's
a coward and the reason why is because
once he's on the losing side he races
off to the ship that they had landed on
and he comes back and he grabs
gaskey now despite being depicted as a
coward in terms of how he fights
essentially hiding behind a friend of
Erica vaisya it's still very effective
because this is now psychological
warfare it's now haven't you know
engaging the conflict in a way that will
mess with the mind of Eric and the
reason why is because he believes his
friend to be dead the funny thing about
this
that commander trail is no true warrior
and the reason why is because when he
looks at Eric he's like hey look I have
your friend if you don't surrender I'm
going to kill your friend now of course
Eric lets his guard down he lets the
armor go he basically surrenders it in
response commander trill kills gawky and
Eric lashes out I mean he absolutely
loses it but that's kind of the crazy
thing is because commander trill didn't
really have any idea what he was doing
one of the things that was easily
established in the very beginning of the
story is that the armored Shawn Hara
really has a mind of its own that's how
it decide who gets to lift it who
doesn't it's very you know Mjolnir in
that sense you know the hammer for a lot
of the relationships that go on incoming
books you know a lot of comic book
publishers you know grab Kings other
publishers and it's a trade off back and
forth you know with regards to this
particular story in a valiant comics you
very much have this Marvel Comics hammer
of Thor situation where the armor of
Shawn Hara chooses who it is that gets
to wield it and the result is that where
XO Man O'War had cast the armor off in
an attempt to basically show that he was
uh that he was basically giving up that
he was surrendering here the result is
that once he puts the armor back on he
takes it to Commander trill and
Commander Cho has no idea what's going
on commander tro has no real
understanding of the conflict that's
taking place before she's calling for
backup he's calling for guys to help him
where he can but the issue is that while
these ships are coming in he's getting
absolutely destroyed by EXO now the
crazy thing about this is that in the
middle of this whole conflict gafty
suddenly emerges when we find out he
didn't actually die the cool thing
though is that EXO is beginning to
understand the capabilities of the armor
and that's the great thing about this
it's been did he's just he's not like
hey like you have this guy Eric Darcy
who just has no idea how any of this
stuff works he has no idea how any of
the function jury just throws new armor
on and that's that's it he's starting to
understand how the armor works and one
of the first things that he recalls is
that where his hand had previously been
cut off while he was aboard divine
mothership the armor healed his hand and
so what he does is he tells the armor
shield asti bond with him and heal him
now the other thing that entity seems to
do here is with the exo-armor it seems
to be like this outward manifestation of
really what a person's feeling how a
person views the world in the sense that
when it bonds itself to Goffe it takes
on a completely different appearance not
wildly different but different enough in
the sense that is you know the spikes
and the scars and the shards as one so
what seem to reflect a mindset of Goffe
in the sense of his mind is very much in
the state of flux he's really kind of
bordering on the realm of insanity
and this comes to fruition when he
starts attacking Eric and the reason why
is because you got to keep him on the
entire time that Eric was here Eric
thought he was dead but in gosse's mind
he's been tortured all this time and so
it almost seemed like Eric basically
left him there that Eric abandoned him
there now again Gabi's not to get
clearly he's not thinking rationally
he's thinking emotionally and he's
thinking with a state of insanity now of
course Eric's able to talk some sense to
him and say hey look man we fought
side-by-side for years and years and
years we will overcome this you have to
regain your mind and that's the great
thing because that's exactly what gasps
she does got Gideon to sort of come to
he begins to understand where it is that
he's at what it is he's doing but we
also get this this last glimpse of
heroism in the sense that with the armor
communicating with him he says look the
fleet's are coming the fleet is coming
here the only way for us to basically be
victorious to keep you from being
destroyed is to destroy the fleet and so
gothy in this last moment of heroism
races off flies into space and begins
the process of tearing these fleets
apart now force that's the cool thing
about the armors because it's literally
a one-man army that's all you need and
that's the reason why it's so
significant to the vine I mean it has
its own religious relic element to it
yes you know the priests look at it as
something that is representation of
their whole races history for the
military this is a weapon that's why
they've been having different members of
the vine race try it on all of whom have
died is because for the military aspect
of the vine society if they're able to
harness this EXO EXO armor they can use
it for virtually anything it so that's
the whole panic here is this armors
wildly powerful if you have an alien
race and there's sloughs of this armor
well suddenly they go from being a
mildly primitive race across the
vastness of the universal States to
being one of the most formidable races
in the universe itself and what happens
is gassy crews this when he basically
begins channeling the energy of the
armor and wiped out the mothership I
mean it's totally obliterates the
Admiral ship so the result is that the
invasion fleet is effectively gone now
of course gassy dies on the cross
cos really him just sort of vanishing
that's the last bit of him so what we do
is we pick up with the tail end of this
we pick up with Vendetti sight in the
stage where he says look in the eyes of
EXO he's lost his friends he has lost
his wife he's lost his life he's lost
everything that made any that had any
real significance in his existence and
so he looks at the vine as the cause of
it and so his goal is to basically
travel back to the vine homeworld and
unleash absolute hell I mean really
bring on a wreck
the likes of which they've never seen
before but if you guys are new here -
how much explain which you guys said the
sub button to become part of the Rob
course you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like Andy yeah extra
metal war is pretty solid I really hope
you guys are digging it but uh yeah I
will catch you all later please
[Music]